Speaker 1: The midterm election season for
2022 is likely to start
Speaker 2: earlier than ever this
Speaker 1: time around.
I was talking to
Speaker 2: our YouTube rep recently, and he
said, expect interest in these
Speaker 1: 2022 midterms to start and to see
more serious
Speaker 2: campaigning and interest on
Speaker 1: YouTube as early as spring of next
year, rather than more like early summer.
And there are some really good reasons why
we would expect that not only are there increasingly
interesting particular races to look at, including
the Texas gubernatorial election where Beto
O'Rourke is running Pennsylvania Senate, we
now have this quack cure promoter Dr. Mehmet
Oz.
Speaker 2: We also have John
Speaker 1: Fetterman running on the Democratic
side.
OK, that's interesting.
So we've got interesting races starting to
fill the
Speaker 2: docket,
Speaker 1: but the stakes are extremely high
in terms of who controls the House and Senate
starting in January of 2023.
And we could go through a long list of reasons
that this is important, including to what
degree Republicans will be able to
Speaker 2: stonewall anything
Speaker 1: Joe Biden tries to do.
They've they've been partially stonewalling
everything so far.
Speaker 2: They might completely
Speaker 1: stonewall everything if they take
control of the house.
But maybe just as importantly, is the reality
that the current Republican Party is wackier
than it has ever been.
And among their goals is this simmering idea
of making Donald Trump speaker of the House.
If they take control of the House of Representatives
in November.
Now you might be saying, Whoa, whoa, stop
the clock.
Speaker 2: David Trump isn't
Speaker 1: running for a house.
How could it be the speaker you may or may
not know?
One does not have to be a member of the House
of Representatives to be speaker of the House,
where I'll talk to Ro Khanna about this when
we have him back on the show soon.
The House can vote for anybody.
If the House decides they want me to be speaker
of the House, I could be speaker of the House.
And starting months ago,
Speaker 2: there was this idea which was mentioned
Speaker 1: on Steve Bannon's bizarre program
of installing Donald Trump as speaker of the
House, even without him being a member of
the House of Representatives, impeaching Joe
Biden and then having Donald Trump preside
over the vote to
Speaker 2: impeach Joe
Speaker 1: Biden in the House beleaguered
radical Republican Congressman
Speaker 2: Matt Gaetz is really
Speaker 1: into this idea.
Starting back in July, he started talking
about
Speaker 2: If we win in twenty two,
Speaker 1: we will make Donald Trump Speaker
of the House.
Speaker 2: And at the
Speaker 1: time, it seemed that it might have
just been a publicity ploy
Speaker 2: to fundraise, get attention,
Speaker 1: maybe raise money for his legal
defense fund.
But Matt Gaetz mentioned it again in August.
And he mentioned it again yesterday.
Senior White House correspondent for Yahoo
News Alexander Nazarian published a tweet
about this, saying quote Matt Gaetz just told
me at a press conference that if Republicans
win the House in twenty two, he will move
to install Trump as House speaker.
So there are really three questions here.
Question one Is Matt Gaetz serious?
He appears to be.
Second question.
Would Republicans actually nominate Trump
to be speaker of the House if they took control?
Speaker 2: And the third question is, if
Speaker 1: nominated, would
Speaker 2: Republicans overall
Speaker 1: actually vote to make Donald Trump
speaker of the House?
The answers to the first two questions are
pretty simple.
Matt Gaetz is serious,
Speaker 2: and I do think that Donald Trump
would be
Speaker 1: nominated for speaker of the House
if Republicans take control in 2022.
The third question is the key question just
because Republicans take control and someone
nominates Trump to be speaker.
Do they really elect Trump to be speaker
Speaker 2: of the House?
Speaker 1: Understand that it's an open question,
not morally, but strategically.
If Trump is don't do particularly well in
the November midterms.
If Donald Trump's power within the party seems
diminished, it's less likely that Republicans
would be willing
Speaker 2: to do something so cartoonish.
Speaker 1: On the other hand, and particularly
if Republicans take control of the House
Speaker 2: on the basis of many
Speaker 1: Trumpists winning new seats in
the House, it is completely
Speaker 2: plausible
Speaker 1: that Republicans would
Speaker 2: be willing to make Trump
Speaker 1: speaker of the House, and it would
be one of the most cartoonish and pathetic
circumstances in American politics in a very,
very long time.
Unfortunately, the combination of historical
trends where the first midterm after a new
president is usually bad for that party, meaning
it would be bad for Democrats in November
combined.
The gerrymandering comment, combined with
population shifts that might see Democrats
losing a few seats just on that basis.
Speaker 2: It is looking
Speaker 1: more and more like Republicans
are going to win the House in November.
It's not a
Speaker 2: guarantee, and when I
Speaker 1: say that, I'm not saying it so
that we do nothing.
I'm saying it so that we don't throw in the
towel and we actually fight for the house
because if we lose that house, it's going
to be very, very bad for a long period of
time.